Traductor: Lidia Cámara de la Fuente
Revisor: Ciro Gomez
Imagina un grupo de personas.
¿Qué tamaño crees
que tendría que tener el grupo
para tener más de un 50 % de probabilidad
de que dos personas en el grupo
tengan el mismo día cumpleaños?
Supongamos por el bien
de la argumentación que no hay gemelos,
que cada cumpleaños es
igualmente probable
e ignoremos los años bisiestos.
Tómate un momento para pensarlo.
La respuesta puede
parecer sorprendentemente baja.
En un grupo de 23 personas,
hay un 50,73 % de probabilidad de que dos
personas tengan el mismo día cumpleaños.
Pero con 365 días en un año,
¿cómo es posible que solo se necesite
un grupo tan pequeño
para obtener incluso la probabilidad
de un mismo cumpleaños?
¿Por qué nuestra intuición
está tan equivocada?
Para averiguar la respuesta,
echemos un vistazo a cómo un matemático
calcularía las probabilidades
de un mismo cumpleaños.
Podemos utilizar un campo de las
matemáticas conocido como combinatorias,
que se ocupa de las probabilidades
de las combinaciones diferentes.
El primer paso es
dar la vuelta al problema.
Tratar de calcular directamente
las probabilidades de coincidir es un reto
porque hay muchas maneras de hacer
coincidir un mismo cumpleaños en un grupo.
En cambio, es más fácil
calcular la probabilidad
de que el cumpleaños
de todos sea diferente.
¿Cómo ayuda esto?
O hay una coincidencia
de cumpleaños en el grupo, o no la hay,
Así que las probabilidades de
coincidir y las de que no coincidan
deben sumar 100 %.
Eso significa que podemos encontrar
la probabilidad de coincidencia
restando la probabilidad
de no coincidencia de un 100 %.
Para calcular las probabilidades
de no coincidencia, empieza pequeño.
Calcula la probabilidad de que solo un par
de personas tengan cumpleaños diferentes.
Un día del año será
el cumpleaños de la Persona A,
lo que deja 364 posibles
cumpleaños para la Persona B.
La probabilidad de diferentes cumpleaños
para A y B o cualquier par de personas,
es de 364 de 365,
un 0,997 o 99,7 %.
¡Bastante alta!
Añade la persona C.
La probabilidad de que ella tenga
un cumpleaños único en este pequeño grupo
es de 363 sobre 365
porque hay dos fechas de nacimiento
ya ocupadas por A y B.
Las probabilidades de D serán
de 362 sobre 365 y así sucesivamente,
hasta las probabilidades
de W de 343 sobre 365.
Multiplica todos estos datos juntos,
y obtendrás la probabilidad
de que nadie coincida en un cumpleaños.
Esto resulta en 0,4927,
lo que significa que hay
un 49,27% de probabilidad de que nadie
en el grupo de 23 comparta un cumpleaños.
Cuando restamos eso a 100,
obtenemos un 50,73 % de probabilidad
de que al menos haya
una coincidencia de cumpleaños,
más incluso que las no coincidencias.
La clave para una probabilidad tan alta
de coincidencia en un grupo pequeño
es el número sorprendentemente
grande de pares posibles.
Si un grupo crece, el número
de combinaciones posibles
aumenta mucho más rápidamente.
Un grupo de cinco personas
tiene diez pares posibles.
Cada una de las cinco puede emparejarse
con cualquiera de las otras cuatro.
La mitad de esas combinaciones
son redundantes
porque emparejar la persona A con la B
es la misma que emparejar B con A,
así que dividimos por dos.
Por el mismo razonamiento,
un grupo de 10 personas tiene 45 parejas,
y un grupo de 23 tiene 253.
el número de pares crece cuadráticamente,
lo que significa que es
proporcional al cuadrado
del número de personas en el grupo.
Desafortunadamente,
nuestros cerebros son notoriamente malos
al captar intuitivamente
funciones no lineales.
Por eso parece improbable que 23 personas
puedan producir 253 pares posibles.
Una vez que los cerebros lo aceptan, el
problema del cumpleaños tiene más sentido.
Todos los 253 pares tienen probabilidad
de coincidencia de cumpleaños.
Por la misma razón,
en un grupo de 70 personas,
hay 2.415 pares posibles,
y la probabilidad de que
dos personas tengan el mismo día
cumpleaños es de más del 99,9 %.
El problema del cumpleaños es un ejemplo
donde las matemáticas pueden mostrar
qué cosas que parecen imposibles,
como que la misma persona
gane la lotería dos veces,
en realidad no son nada improbables.
A veces las coincidencias
no son tan coincidentes como parecen.